[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS ORYSCHAK:
Everyone, good morning.
Thanks for being here.
I'm Chris, and I'm a PM at
Fabric, and now Firebase.
And I'm also a co-founder.
I was a co-founder
of a mobile start-up.
So I know firsthand
from experience,
and from talking to
customers like you,
just how hard it is
to get more users.
Building a really good growth
funnel is insanely hard.
It's always changing.
It's super complex.
And so, as a PM over
last couple years,
I've been focused
on this problem
of growth for mobile apps.
And especially focused on the
identity portion of growth.
And a lot of people
don't think identity
is a really important part
of growth and growth hacking
and whatever.
But actually, it really is.
Because you can have an
amazing onboarding funnel,
but if people can't, or
won't, log in to your app,
then you don't get a user.
You don't have growth.
And so it's super important.
And we've especially seen
a lot of great success
with using phone numbers as a
effective identity for growth.
So, why phone numbers?
One, they have a lot
of great benefits.
One, they're global.
Every single person in the
world who has a smartphone
has a phone number that
they have memorized.
And, actually, in a lot
of emerging markets,
we've learned that people
prefer to use their phone
numbers as their identity
instead of an email address
or another form
of identification.
And second, phone numbers
are higher quality.
They give you higher
quality users.
Because they're more
expensive to mass produce,
they're naturally resistant to
the kinds of abuse and fraud
you might see more often in
other types of identification.
And also, I think
most importantly
for this discussion,
is they enable really
low-friction sign-in
for apps and websites.
And again, like I said, sign-in
is such an important part
of your growth funnel.
Over 90% of people who have
issues logging in to an app
are going to leave.
And so I think it's
a scary number,
but I think it's a great
opportunity that if you really
focus on identity
as part of growth,
you can have really
awesome benefits.
And so, if identity is
so important to growth,
then why is login
so hard to use?
And I think, as app
developers, as web developers,
we created the login screens.
And so why are we making
these screens so hard to use?
And over the years, I've
noticed there's really two big,
I think, two big areas of why
login is so high friction.
One big one is in a
problem of optimization.
We're trying to do so much
in a little screen that
should be simple.
Instead-- in addition
to just trying
to log somebody in,
or sign them up,
we're also trying to get
a way to contact them
by getting their email address.
We're also trying to enforce
some level of security,
usually with some sort of
password credential criteria.
And we know as
developers that passwords
don't increase security as much
as they increase frustration
and friction.
One big reason.
Another big reason why
login is so high friction,
is on the opposite
side of the spectrum.
And I'm definitely
guilty of this myself--
is we're so focused on
the core value of the app
that we're creating
that we don't really
spend a lot of time on login.
It's just something
that we threw together
before we shipped.
But the big disconnect there
is that the first screen
our customers see is
a login screen, often.
And so, the last screen
you thought about
is the first screen
your customers
are going to be experiencing.
So huge disconnects.
And those are two big
reasons why there's
a lot of friction in login.
And as developers, we
know that login is harder
than it needs to be.
Most developers are not happy
with their sign-in experience.
But I know it's rational
that we'd rather
focus on the core value of
our apps, our core ideas
that we want to get
out to the world.
And dealing with login is hard.
There's UX implications.
There's security implications.
And it's just not something--
people using our app
is more important to us
than people logging into it, at
least when we're building apps.
And so with all that in
mind, a couple years ago
our team wanted to experiment
taking phone numbers,
and wrapping them into a really
simple log-in experience.
And it looked like this.
Instead of entering your
email address and phone
number, or email
address and password,
you get your phone
number, and in return, you
get a six-digit code.
You push that code in
and you're logged in.
Really simple, secure
log-in with no password.
We took that experience
and dropped it
into a really simple to
use SDK called Digits.
Digits was something that people
from any technical background
could dump into their apps or
websites in a few more moments
than it takes to
actually log into Digits.
And we let it go.
And how it went, was,
I think, pretty well.
Since launching, almost
150 million people
have logged in with Digits
all around the world.
That's been a really fun
ride, and we've learned a lot.
But I think what
I've really enjoyed
the most is talking to
developers like you,
and hearing your
stories about the things
that you care about when it
comes to growth and identity
in an authentication.
And, obviously, performance
is a huge factor to that.
Our good friends at DoubleT
replaced email login
with phone.
That's one of the
options for their app.
And they saw a 45% increase
in sign-in in rates.
Imagine your own growth funnel,
and making one small change
that can give you 45% more
users everyday into your app.
I think that that's cool
for a couple reasons.
One, it shows that phone
is a legitimate way
to log people in.
And second, it shows
that, back like I said,
any changes you can make to the
identity portion of your growth
funnel might have huge
impacts for your entire growth
all the way through.
Or Musical.ly, who is improving
the quality of their accounts
by enforcing Digits
on phone verification.
So what they're doing is
they're reducing fraud
on their in-app economy,
which I think is
a really smart use of Digits.
Again on trust,
Periscope, they're
early partners of Digits,
and they're still using us.
And by letting us handle their
onboarding flow for them,
they're able to focus
on the core value, which
is delivering a live video to
people anywhere in the world.
Or Dubsmash, who,
again, they relied on us
to handle almost two
million people per month
through Dubsmash,
so that they can
focus on the core value of
what they offer to customers.
And so, these kind of topics
have come up over and over
again--
trust, performance,
and reliability.
And performance has always
been the biggest thing,
because, frankly, you
hired us to do a job.
The job is to give
you more users.
And we wanted to
give you more users.
And so, earlier this year
when we joined Google,
we saw this really
amazing opportunity
to take all the
iteration and UX research
that you put into Digits'
kit, and combine it
with a really
unique capabilities
that Google has to offer.
And so we put our heads
down, and a couple days ago,
you saw some really
cool announcements.
And I think that
what we came up with
are some really awesome next
evolutions in phone auth
performance,
together in Firebase.
And so to share how you can
take advantage of that today,
we're going to be
talking about two topics.
One, for those of you who are
already managing your own SMS
backend, you know
how hard it can
be to actually get a
well-formatted phone
number from a customer.
And so, you'll see some
really cool new APIs
that we're going to
be discussing first.
And second, I'm really excited
to be sharing Firebase, more
details on Firebase phone
authentication, which
has been a really
tight collaboration
between the Digits
engineering team
and Firebase to create a brand-m
new service that, I think,
is philosophically
and effectively
the next logical
evolution of what
we want to do with Digits
in terms of phone auth
performance.
It's a really amazing system.
And also has a really
easy to use migration path
for Digits customers.
And so, I would encourage
any Digits customer
to take a look at it.
Because I think
it's really badass.
And so, to get us kicked
off, please welcome Vikas
on stage, who's going to
be talking about phone
selector and SMS retriever.
[APPLAUSE]
VIKAS GUPTA: Thanks,
Chris, and hello, everyone.
My name is Vikas, and I work
in the Android auth team
at Google.
I'm going to talk about how
we enable you to support phone
numbers for
authentication, if you
have an existing backend
infrastructure that you are
already using for verifying
the phone numbers,
such as for sending
SMSs to your users.
You may have your own
SMS infrastructure,
or you might be
using a third party
service such as [INAUDIBLE].
So, as Chris mentioned,
using phone numbers
for authentication
is great, as it
offers several benefits over
traditional authentication
methods.
But still, signing in a
user with phone numbers
is still problematic for some
users and for app developers.
Let's see what a sign-in
experience with phone numbers
looks like today.
It involves two steps.
First, getting the phone
number of the device.
And second, verifying
the phone number.
Most apps perform verification
by sending an SMS to the user's
device with a
one-time verification
code that the application
that verifies.
So the app has to get the
phone number of the device,
and then read the verification
code from the SMS.
So how do the apps
get these two things?
Most of the apps employ--
basically-- ask the users
to enter these values.
But that's not a great
solution, for many reasons.
First, manually inputting
the phone number is painful.
It adds a lot of
friction for the users
to provide phone
numbers to your app.
It's also error-prone.
It's important to note that
every failed verification,
because of a typo
in the phone number,
adds cost to the developers,
because they end up
sending an SMS to the
wrong phone number.
Let's say the user
provides the phone number
and you send the
SMS to the phone.
The next step for you is to
get the verification code
from the SMS.
Again, asking the user to
provide you the verification
code is painful for the users.
It requires the users to leave
your app, go to the SMS app,
copy your--
copy or remember the
verification code from there,
come back to your app,
and then provide it there.
It's a lot of work
for the users.
Many users find it
confusing, and it's not
a great experience.
So, many app developers have
recognized these problems
with the manual imports.
And what they've
started to do is,
they are now reading the
verification code and the phone
number automatically.
But this approach
has its own problems.
Let's see.
Getting the verification--
getting the phone number
from the device and the
verification code from the SMS
automatically requires
your apps to get permission
from the users.
And this looks
something like this.
These permissions
allow the apps to get
the access to all
the phone calls,
and all the SMS
messages of the user.
Users are left confused as
to why our app needs access
to all these phone
calls and SMS messages.
So this leads to a low--
a low adoption rate, and
a poor user experience.
And from privacy
perspective, it's
not a great solution
for your apps.
The Google Play services
SDK, we are offering you
best of both the words.
We enable you to read the phone
number and the verification
code from the SMS
automatically without requiring
these extra permissions.
For reading the phone number,
we have the phone selector API.
And for verifying
the phone number,
we have the SMS retriever API.
Since these APIs are part of
the Google Play services SDK,
they're also compatible
with the older
versions of Android platform.
Let's take a look at the
phone selector API first.
The phone selector API
provides the phone number
to your app with a much
better user experience,
and no extra permissions.
Using this API, you can
launch our dialogue,
which shows the phone numbers
on the device to the user.
When the user selects
the phone number
that they want to use to
sign in into your app,
that phone number is
provided to your app
immediately, without requiring
any extra permissions.
You can check out
the usage of this API
in the apps like Mynthra,
Lyft, and Flipkart.
Let's see how you can
use this API in your app.
First you create a
hint request object,
and st the phone
number identifier
supported field to true.
And then, you get
a pending intent
from that hint request for the
phone number selector dialogue.
Once the user selects
the phone number,
that phone number is
returned to your app
in the on activity
result. It's that simple.
Once you have the phone
number, the next step for you
is to get the verification code
to verify the phone number.
In order to help you with that,
we have the SMS retriever API.
So let's take a look at that.
SMS retriever API provides you
the message content to your app
without requiring any
extra permissions.
And the key part is that it
provides you only the message
targeted the your app.
All you have to do is--
you have in your SMS message,
in addition to the verification
code, you have to include
an app-specific hash.
This app-specific
hash is a static hash
that you can just include
in the SMS template
without requiring
many code changes.
Let's see how you can use SMS
retriever API in your app.
When you want to
verify the user's phone
number on the device, you
start the SMS retriever.
This makes it wait for
one matching SMS, which
includes the app-specific hash.
After starting
the SMS retriever,
you can just send the SMS
with the verification code
and the app-specific
hash to the phone
using any backend
infrastructure of yours.
Once the SMS with
the app-specific hash
is received on the
device, it is provided
to your app via a broadcast.
In your broadcast receiver,
you can get the message content
from the extras.
Once you have the
message content,
you can extract the
verification code,
and verify the code just
like you would normally do.
The SMS retriever
API, you can use it
for not just signing
in the users,
but also for the alt-use
cases, such as for payments.
The SMS retriever API will
be available in Google Play
services.
It will be available
in the Google Play
services in the coming weeks.
But our early partners who have
tried this API have loved it.
Here are some testimonials
from some of our partners.
Many of our
partners, like Authy,
they love the fact that it works
with-- that these APIs work
with their existing
infrastructure.
We have carefully
designed our APIs
so that they are very easy to
integrate with your existing
flows.
Mynthra, for example, was
able to successfully integrate
the SMS retriever API in
their existing sign-in flows
in just three days
with one engineer.
Here are other testimonials.
Many of our apps have
been able to get rid
of the scary permissions and
streamline the phone number
verification flows
because of our APIs.
Kaskus Chat actually found out
that their conversion rates
increased after they integrated
their flows with our APIs.
So, I just talked about how
with phone selector API and SMS
retriever API, we enable you
to simplify the phone auth
process if you already have
a backend infrastructure
in place.
Next, we are going to talk
about the Firebase phone
auth, which helps you get
started with the phone auth.
And if you're looking for
an end-to-end solution,
this is how it will help you.
So with that,
please welcome Dev,
who is going to talk more
about the Firebase phone auth.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DEVVRET RISHI: Thank you, Vikas.
And hello, everybody.
My name is Dev Rishi, and
I'm the product manager
for Firebase authentication.
You heard about some
really cool things
that phone number authentication
can do for your application.
And today, I'm really excited
to talk to you about how
Firebase phone auth can
make it possible to build
all of these really great flows
end to end, and very easily.
So before we start,
I feel like I have
to acknowledge that as soon--
since we've launched,
phone number authentication
has been one of our top
feature requests constantly.
To all the developers
that tweeted,
posted on Stack Overflow,
or filed a feature request,
I just want to say
that we've heard you.
And we're really excited
to be able to bring
this functionality
to Firebase now.
And it's no surprise
that so many people
have been asking for this.
Today's apps need to
be able to support
high-quality, low-friction
users from all over the world,
and engage with
them in new ways.
And that makes phone number
auth really valuable.
But truth is, for a lot of the
apps that actually don't have
phone number
authentication today,
building it in the first
place can be a real struggle.
Chris talked about a lot of the
pains that users go through.
It's also really painful
for a lot of developers.
First thing you'll need to do is
integrate with an SMS provider,
and get coverage with
carriers to send SMS.
And then, you're going to
want to expand your offering
globally to support all the
different areas that your users
might come from, making sure
you've perfectly localized
along the way.
After all of that, you need to
build secure authentication.
That means generating a one-time
code, verifying it from a user,
minting cryptographically
signed tokens,
persisting sessions, writing
your anti-abuse logic.
I don't know about
you, but that's not
exactly what I was
looking forward to when
I started to write an app.
That's why I'm really
excited to tell you
that this week Firebase launched
its phone authentication APIs.
The first thing
that we allow is we
enable basic sign-in
and sign-up flows.
Similar to what Chris talked
about earlier with Digits
on all the platforms
that we support--
iOS, Android, and web.
And, on Android, we actually
allow for a few and built--in
enhancements.
Vikas told you a little
bit about the SMS retriever
API, which actually increases
overall conversions from users
so they don't have to end
up going to the SMS app
and parsing it.
And I'm excited to
announce that this
is going to come built
in to our Android APIs.
Finally, we have a
really new cool piece
of functionality called instant
verification on Android.
And I can't wait to tell
you a bit more about that.
The iOS and web
APIs are actually
available for you to
start trying today.
And the Android APIs will
be coming in a few weeks.
But in the meantime,
let's go ahead and see
what these APIs are capable of.
First thing that we want to make
sure we enable your app to do
is allow you to sign in
and sign up your users.
So for example, if
you're on an iPhone,
the flow might look
a lot like this.
Perhaps you're one of
the many modern apps
that integrates email
authentication, as well as
different identity providers.
And in this case, you decide
to go ahead and sign in
with phone number.
All a user would need to do
is enter their phone number,
and you can go ahead
and pass it over to us.
We'll validate the phone number,
handle any normalization logic
that needs to
happen, see if this
is a new user, or a returning
one, and we'll go ahead
and generate a one-time code
associated with this request.
From there, we'll handle
sending this one-time code
through an SMS to your end
user, so you don't worry
about any of those pieces.
New user will simply pass back
the code into your application,
and which you would just
pass right back on to us,
and we will verify it.
We'll handle any of the complex
logic, and deduplication,
if you sent multiple
SMS by mistake,
or any of the other edge
cases that might arise.
And the user will go ahead
and enter their code.
We'll validate it.
And we'll go ahead and
mint cryptographically
signed tokens, persist sessions,
the whole authentication nine
yards, and you
won't have to worry
about how any of it, because
all you'll have to worry about
is how to best and
warmly welcome your users
into your application.
So that's kind of
what the actual APIs
look like for signing in
and signing up users on all
the platforms that we support--
iOS, Android, and web.
And I'm really excited to talk
about some of the enhancements
that we're able to
make on Android.
The first one is
auto retrieval, which
works very similarly to what
Vikas discussed earlier.
And comes built in, the
user phone auth APIs.
For auto retrieval, if the
user goes ahead and click
sign with phone number.
This time, they can actually
select their phone number,
if you integrate
with hint selector.
It'll be auto-populated
into the application.
We'll validate it once more.
We'll set-- we'll
generate the code.
But this time, when we actually
send the code in the SMS,
we'll be able to pick it
up from the background.
We'll auto-retrieve it directly,
parse it out, and populate it
into the application.
And the best part
of all of this,
is your user never actually
had to leave your application,
go to an SMS tab, wait for
it, and then copy and paste
the code into your UI.
They stayed in your
application the entire time.
And it's a really seamless
experience for them overall.
That's all that you
ever have to do.
The last piece of
infrastructure that I'm really
excited to talk
to you about today
is a new feature on
Android that we're
calling instant verification.
Instant verification works
exactly like it sounds like.
It allows us to verify the phone
number without sending an SMS.
And to the user, it
appears instantly.
Let's take a quick
look at how it works.
In this case, user might
see this screen again,
where they get to select
a phone number, directly,
that we read off their device.
This time, when they
enter their phone number,
and you call their APIs, we're
going to do a first check.
That check will go ahead and see
if we have verified this phone
number on the device recently.
If we have, we can
actually instantly
verify the phone
number the next time
around without needing to
send any additional SMS.
We think that this
means there's no wait
time, no SMS, or anything
else, just pure simplicity.
I'm really excited
about the potential
this has to significantly
improve user experience,
and greatly simplify the
lives of our developers.
I think one of my favorite
things about Firebase phone
auth is that all this
powerful functionality is also
really easy to use.
There is just essentially
just two steps
to go ahead and get started.
The first thing you need to
do is just enable phone auth
within your project in
the Firebase console.
This is, quite literally,
clicking on the phone selector,
and enabling phone auth
with a simple flag flip.
It doesn't actually get
much easier than that.
The second thing
you need to do is
just integrate with
our SDKs in our APIs
in order to be able to
use this functionality.
Now, our headless APIs
don't enforce any UI,
so they give you
programmatic access
to our underlying infrastructure
that you can use in any way
that you choose.
And it's really easy to use.
On Android, in order to get
all the awesome functionality
that I talked about, the actual
ability to generate and send
codes, the auto-retrieval,
even instant verification,
comes down to just
one single API call,
and the implementation of the
callbacks that you care about.
So in this case, all you do
is call verify phone number
with a phone number
that you pass in,
and implement a few callbacks.
For example, on
verification completed,
where you can decide whatever
it is you like to do,
once we've either auto-retrieved
the SMS, instantly verified
the phone number, or
whenever the user just
decided to be signed in.
I think all of
this functionality
is really powerful.
These APIs are very simple
to use, and give you
programmatic access
to some of our most
incredible infrastructure
here at Google.
But I think it's really
worth asking, what about UI?
Building authentication
UI can be pretty complex.
You need to handle all
sorts of edge cases
across all the
different platforms
your application might support.
And even after you
do all of that,
you want to make sure that
your log-in UI is actually
high performance.
And that will give you
good conversion rates.
As Chris talked
about earlier, this
isn't really what a lot of you
want to spend your time doing.
The first screen
that your users see
is often the last screen
that you think about.
And building out all this
UI can honestly be painful.
Trust us, we know.
Because we've actually done it.
We wrote out all the code
for the different phone
authentication flows that
we've talked about just
for the UI components on
Android, iOS, and web.
And just to write the
phone authentication flows
across the three platforms,
it can be several thousands
of lines of code.
Now if you decide to go the way
of a lot of modern applications
and integrate different identity
providers, such as Google,
Facebook, email, et
cetera, then this
is just going to
get more complex.
And if you actually
end up wanting
to integrate all these
different sign-in
providers into your
application, well,
doing identity and user
sign-up is probably
going to become
your full-time job.
That's why I'm really
excited to announce
that Firebase phone auth is
now also part of Firebase UI.
And Firebase UI is an open
source repository on GitHub
that we maintain that gives you
the best practices in sign-in
and sign-up that
Google has studied
over a long history of
doing identity work directly
and out of the box
for your applications.
This is really bringing
years and years of knowledge
from Google's
understanding of how
to maximize conversion rates
directly into your application.
It's really simple to
integrate into your app.
And it gives you the
best practice flows
for all the different platforms.
Best of all, Firebase UI
is completely open source,
and fully customizable.
So soon as you integrate
it into your application,
you can go ahead and
tweak and tailor it
directly into the
needs of your app,
however you decide
you'd like to.
But you don't just have
to take my word for it
on how easy Firebase
UI is to use,
and how easy these
APIs are to integrate.
I can actually show you.
So I call this part of my talk
"what could possibly go wrong?"
Because it is not
only a live demo
that I'd like to do
in order to show you
the cool functionality
and how easy
it is to build
into applications,
but before this
week, I've actually
never touched a line of
Android code before in my life.
Luckily, building
phone authentication
is actually really easy.
And I'm going to
be able to do it,
I hope, in just a couple of
minutes into my application.
So before this demo,
the only thing I've done
is actually create a project.
And you can tell, there is
not a lot going on here.
Not sure I could actually
do that much more.
All I've done so far is
just get the dependencies.
As you know, the public
versions of the Android APIs
will be coming out
in a few weeks.
From here, I can actually
build phone authentication
into my application in
just three simple steps.
The first step is I'm going to
link Firebase to my application
through this super easy
use Android Studio plugin.
I'll go ahead and go to
authentication, click Email
Password, and, as you can see,
I've set up my dependencies.
And I'll just hit
Connect to Firebase.
This is going to open
up a dialogue that'll
allow me either create
a new Firebase project,
or link to an existing one.
This case, I'm
just going to link
to easy auth, which
is the Firebase
project that I'd set up.
Now that I've connected
to it, I'm going to--
that was step one.
Connecting this through the
through the Android Studio
plugin was all I needed
to do for step one.
And step two is even easier.
I'm just going to go over
to the Firebase console,
go to the authentication
tab, go to sign-in methods.
And here, we can see all the
different sign-in methods
that Firebase authentication
currently supports.
I've already configured
a few in the past,
like email, Google,
and Facebook.
And I'm just going
to enable phone.
This part is, quite
literally, just
that flag flip I
showed you earlier,
and we're done with step two.
Now if you'll believe
me, step three
is just as easy as the
last two, even though it's
the step where we write code.
All I'm going to do is go to the
open source Firebase UI GitHub
repository, scroll through the
read me, ignore most of it,
and go to this one
section that I care about,
where I'll be able
to copy and paste
the code directly
into my application
to get my phone auth
UI built. Now this
allows me to support a lot of
different sign-in providers,
like the ones you saw before.
And in this demo,
instead of Twitter,
I'm going to decide to
support phone verification.
That was it.
That's all I had to do.
Luckily, because, again,
I don't actually--
I'm not actually an
Android developer,
once I go ahead and
compile this application--
if I could switch
to my phone, please.
Thank you.
I will be able to show you
exactly all the different flows
that we integrate
with, end to end.
So now, I have multiple
different log-in methods
enabled on my demo
app very easily.
And I can show you
exactly how the phone
auth flows work in real life.
Fingers crossed I have
carrier coverage here.
First thing you'll notice
is Firebase UI integrates
with hint selector directly.
So I didn't write any
additional code for this.
But it's able to pick up my
phone number from the device,
and I can just simply enter
it directly to the app.
Now when I hit
verify phone number,
it'll go ahead and send me
a code which will directly
get right off the SMS--
and I don't know if
you actually caught it
because it was so fast.
But the number was--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
The code was sent to my
device immediately written
from the SIM.
But from the end
user perspective,
it was the easiest
thing I've done all day.
And all I did was really
tap my phone number,
and everything else
was taken for me.
The SMS was delivered.
It was parsed.
It was taken.
I never left the app.
Now let's imagine that I'm
coming back to the application,
maybe after a week or
two, and I'd signed out.
This time I'm going
to try and demo
a really cool piece
of functionality
that I'd mentioned earlier--
instant verification.
This time around, when
I go to the application,
let's sign in with a
phone number again.
It'll pull up the phone
number for my device
just like last time.
And I hope what's
going to happen
is I'm just going to
do single tap log-in.
Where I go ahead and
select my phone number,
it sees that I'd already
been verified in the past,
and that was it.
No SMS was sent, nothing else.
Can we see an instant
replay, maybe?
Because that was so quick.
There was no SMS sent.
There was no need for a
user to wait for anything.
But instead, we were
able to just validate
that we verified it, and
logged them in directly
into the application.
So I'm really excited about this
functionality, the potential
it as for where we
can go in the future.
And I can't wait to
see how you integrate
into your applications.
Can we go back to the slides?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I think one of the
things you just saw
is how easy it was to
build Firebase phone
authentication from scratch.
And I think one other thing
that we've thought about a lot,
as we've actually
developed this,
is how do we make sure we have
the best possible experience
for Digits developers?
As Chris mentioned earlier,
building Firebase phone
authentication was a
really close collaboration
between the Firebase auth
and the Digits teams.
And we want to make
sure that we're
able to warmly welcomed Digits
into the Firebase family.
That's why I'm happy to announce
that we've started to roll out
migration pathways
for Digits developers,
where they'll be able to
link their Fabric accounts
with Firebase projects.
And we'll handle the user
importation and all other tasks
required in order for
them to get set up
for their first time.
From there, they can go ahead
and use the migration guides
that'll be published
soon in order
to integrate the new Firebase
SDKs into the application.
And that's all they
should have to do.
There won't be any additional
friction for your users
who won't have to necessarily
reauthenticate back
into your application.
And I hope all of you
stay tuned on the Fabric
site for the coming details.
I'm really excited that we've
launched phone authentication,
because I think now Firebase
is an even more comprehensive
authentication solution.
Now we support all the
different major sign-in methods
your application
might want to support,
like email authentication,
phone numbers, and some
of the top identity providers,
like Facebook, Google, Twitter,
and GitHub.
We also give you easy
user management UI
from the console,
as well as SDKs
in order to do all the different
tasks that you might want to
on behalf.
You can bring your own custom
authentication solution
to Firebase if you've
already have one.
And I think, best
of all, we give you
drop-in and fully
customizable open source UI
that reflects Google's
best practices.
So you never have
to worry about how
to best write the conversion
flows for your application.
You never have to worry about
all the thousands of lines
of code that it might take.
I think one of things
that's great about Firebase
authentication is that
most of the services
are completely free to use.
And I'm really excited to
say that with phone auth,
we've spent a lot
of time thinking
about how do we come up with the
most friendly pricing structure
for the developers as possible.
We have a really
generous free tier,
where I think for up to 10,000
verifications per month,
we're actually going to be able
to give all the verifications
under the threshold for free.
This will cover the vast
majority of applications.
And I think it's more
than 90% of Digits apps
developers will be able to
use the service completely
for free.
If you do you grow
wildly successful,
we want to make sure that
our service continues
to grow sustainably
and scalably with you.
We also want to
make sure that we
give you really simple and
easy to understand pricing.
So we're only
going to charge you
based on what you
care about, which
is the actual
verification of the user.
And we're going to make the
pricing structure really
simple.
Just $0.01 for verification
in US, Canada, and India,
and $0.06 in the
rest of the world,
for any of the
verifications that
go above and beyond the
10,000 verifications a month.
I can't wait to see
what you all build
when this is in your hands.
So, to recap kind of on
what we've talked today,
we really talked about
two sets of optimizations
I think Google is enabling for
all the different applications
out there that care
about phone numbers.
If you have your own phone
auth infrastructure already,
there's phone hint selector
and SMS auto-retrieval in order
to really optimize those
flows, and make your end user
experiences much better.
If you want to build
a phone authentication
solution from scratch,
Firebase phone authentication
will give you the
entire process,
end to end, with some of
our built-in enhancements
very easily.
And I think is a
really compelling way
to start getting
into this space,
and being able to integrate
this powerful technology
into your applications.
Like I said before, the iOS
and web APIs for Firebase phone
auth are out now.
And the Android
APIs for everything
will be coming out
in the coming weeks.
But in the meantime,
I do hope that you'll
go ahead and check
out our documentation,
try us out today.
And if you have any
questions whatsoever,
all of our contact information
is listed out on the screen.
And we'll be hanging
out outside these tents
and in the Firebase
sandbox for a little bit
afterwards as well.
I really cannot wait to see
what you build with this new
technology.
I'm really excited
to help and continue
to support our developers.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]